make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are covering x of swords
creation right this this ex of swords
event is a big event this is a 22 part
series uh i have no idea what all is in
store for us here i really have no clue
i have no earthly clue but um here's the
thing we're going to cover x-men number
12 and we're going to cover this
because in typical jonathan hickman
fashion one rolls directly into the
other and it's one of the reasons why i
held off on recording this just because
of the fact that after reading x-men
issue number 12 it became obvious that
exosours was just going to roll over and
it'd be easy to kind of record them at
once as opposed to trying to record you
know one and then like waiting a week
and trying to record the other because
then it would end up throwing people off
right so um what this first part does
because we're doing like so much here
because we have so much going on what
we're gonna do here is kind of focus on
the main points
right and one of the main points here is
we basically end up picking up with
summoner now summoner here is kind of
hanging out with a few of the x-men that
are around there or at least kind of the
newer generation and so on and so forth
but he's met by the arrival of
apocalypse and what this is served
really designed to do is for us to kind
of get this explanation
on the nature of a rocco right now the
idea behind this
is that when it when it comes to aracho
and krakowa as we're told here
that initially they were one singular
island and that much we already knew but
we already knew that okara was basically
the name of this pangaea type you know
chunk of land and that when this whole
thing was when this whole thing existed
at some point in time it was just a
single land mass
but then somebody managed to get their
hands on the twilight sword now we're
not told
who it was that was in possession of the
twilight sword but this is a big deal
because the twilight sword is a is the
weapon of certain right meaning somebody
got a hold
of surtur's weapon and then used it to
quite literally
cleave okara in half to cut the island
in half the problem with this is that
when that happened
demons and dark beings started rising
from this massive fissure and so in
order to bring an end to this in order
to stop this
basic you know this invasion more or
less apocalypse assembled his four
horsemen and they basically attacked and
fought back the demon horde but the
problem with this was that in order to
seal the rift
apocalypse's four horsemen had to be
confined within a rocco and basically
sealed off right and sealed away that's
why we've never heard of them before
right because they've literally just
been left inside this landmass this
entire time and so with all the various
forces of apocalypse being sealed here
in addition to his four horsemen they
basically had to make life on their own
and when they arrived down here what
they started to realize
is that this place was a dark and
horrible place right it was more or less
health now hickman doesn't say as much
he doesn't tell us this is like the
realm of mephisto and in fact it just
seems to be a dark dimension right just
one of the many dark dimensions that
exists out there in marvel comics it's
just one that hasn't really been
explored yet but with all these demons
and all these horrible entities out
there
the first thing that the forces of
apocalypse did was basically find a way
to keep themselves protected and so they
essentially use their ability to tap
into into sorcery and these these
mutants who were basically summoners the
abilities
you know the ability to use witchcraft
so alchemy that kind of a thing started
erecting these tin towers
and and these 10 towers were basically
kind of like these borders right so we
could largely assume
that they created some kind of a
protective protective field around this
giant chunk of land
and that's where all the forces of
apocalypse resided now apocalypse's wife
at the time
a woman named genesis was part of these
forces who were confined here and the
result was that you ended up seeing the
horsemen of apocalypse
basically having their own offspring in
this instance we ended up having war
basically who became the mother of
summoner now genesis became the de facto
leader of this group here there was a
council of sorts but all the indications
here are that genesis was kind of the
final voice right that there's a council
but it's like anything else in this
world if you go high enough
you always reach one person and that's
what it was here right when you go high
enough among the ranks you get to one
person then it basically has
absolute authority and that's what ended
up happening now the idea of genesis was
to basically travel
outward and to annihilate their enemies
right instead of basically living in
kind of a safe haven they'd created for
themselves to go out there
into morocco and to slaughter their
enemies wherever they found them
the problem with this is that they were
basically fighting against the forces of
amnesty is essentially what it's called
but hickman kind of plays this fast and
loose we're not really told if amnet is
a person or amnest is an ideology right
we're not really given the given any
differentiation there we're simply told
the forces of amnest
no the forces of a myth rather uh but
the idea here is that
during this time or at least somewhere
around this time you ended up having
what was basically the greatest of their
healers right this guy who you know this
guy was basically wielding the white
sword and the whole purpose behind this
is that this guy
basically set out and he was
annihilating the forces of of
uh of a myth as well the problem with
this was the longer he fought the more
he became
engulfed in the war that they were
fighting and so the power of his sword
the power of purity was such that he had
his 100 warriors and what would happen
is they would go out they would fight
against these forces and basically all
his warriors would die and the power of
the white sword is that it would all
resurrect them and they would go right
back out again the next day the issue is
that again
they became kind of lost in their
conflict it's almost like thor when he
goes into his warriors madness and he
just doesn't he doesn't really able to
determine friend from
foe that's exactly what happened here
these guys were not able to determine or
able to look at the forces of genesis
and see them as allies
they were all deemed as being enemies in
the face of white sword right and so
what ends up happening here is that
once they face off against this threat
who is at one point the greatest of
their healers
their numbers were absolutely crushed
right literally
they were pushed to the like the forces
of genesis were pushed to near
extinction and so traveling back to
their base of operations ultimately you
ended up seeing a character by the name
of iska who showed
up and isca was considered a traitor but
not by choice she wasn't a traitor
because of the fact that she was like
this group sucks they obviously lost
there's no way they can win i'm just
gonna defect
her mutant power is such that she cannot
lose right and so though the idea here
is that if she's in a situation
like this and she recognizes the forces
of genesis cannot win against the forces
of amith and they cannot win against the
forces of white sword then her mutant
power
drives her to ally with the winning side
and that basically drove her to become a
traitor and to ally herself with ammon
this is jonathan hickman basically
saying that amith is the one who's going
to come out on top there's no possible
way for anybody else to win it's
basically telling us like what's going
to happen and that's exactly what does
play out now when iska shows up she
essentially says that annihilation
basically the the god general of ammon
has is has challenged her to a duel and
the way this duel will play out
is that if annihilation falls if
annihilation loses in this battle to the
death then the forces of ammon will back
off and they will leave these guys to do
their own thing
but if genesis falls then it leaves the
way open for the forces of amith to
invade right and that's exactly what
goes on here that when this battle takes
place
the the fight between genesis and
annihilation is intense right it's an
extreme battle
but ultimately genesis falls and when
she falls this leaves the way or kind of
paves the way for the forces of amith to
basically start
invading into these territories now it's
not done overnight you're talking about
a very large
chunk of land and so this battle
stretches on for for quite some time not
only that it's not as though genesis
fell
and the entire place was you know had to
lay down their arms and let themselves
be invaded
they fought as best they could but they
were hopelessly outmatched it was really
just a battle of attrition right just
the numbers just kept coming and coming
and these guys just couldn't hold off
you know any longer and so in a
last-ditch effort they ended up sending
summoner to the main marvel universe
basically sending him to the surface
world in hopes that he could find
apocalypse and that in finding
apocalypse he'd be able to bring the
full might of his power
down to a rocco and then basically
cleanse everything that apocalypse could
be the one to face off against
annihilation
and then probably defeat annihilation or
possibly even go as far as to defeat
ammon
and so in order to achieve this what you
ended up getting was apocalypse who
basically allied
or brought back banshee who of course
has the ability to you know sonic
energies more or less uh the ability to
kind of emanate a sonic voice as well as
unis the untouchable now unis the
untouchable is kind of a stupid
character at least he was but that's one
of the cool things about what hickman's
doing is hickman's very very good at
taking characters that would otherwise
be considered laughable and turn him
into somebody interesting and that's
what he's done here
luna's the untouchable is a guy that
basically has a force field he can make
a force field around himself and the
only way to get past his force field is
to somehow manage to take over his mind
that's the only way to really do it
short of that there's
no real way to get past his force field
and to to get to him directly and so
they're really designed to be sent there
as scouts right to basically report on
everything that's going on
and then at the same time apocalypse
intends to essentially bring together
the full forces of krakowa
and then travel into a rocco and then
liberate the entire territory right
liberate all the land and so what you
end up doing here
is switching over to the exodus swords
event itself right and this basically
opens up with the four horsemen of
apocalypse who looked to appear to be
leading the forces of ammonth right who
looked to basically be the ones who were
kind of leading this whole charge and
what you end up getting are you know is
really just kind of the
the king of the mutants or at least the
king of this one territory and the idea
is to kind of send out somebody to
basically alert saturnine to make
saturnine aware of what's going on so at
the very least
saturnine can send her own forces you
know to kind of try to quell this threat
to bring the power that she possesses to
bear on this particular force
the issue with this is that as that
happens you end up having this one
particular
this one particular you know scout this
one guy this messenger who's taken out
and following that he basically washes
up on the shores of saturnine right he
walks washes up on the starlight citadel
now a little bit of explanation here for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this this starlight citadel
is both a base of operations as well as
kind of a holy place
right so the idea is that in marvel
comics you have what's called the
captain britain core
most of you guys know about that and you
have one captain britain in every
universe right and the idea here is that
they all basically gain their abilities
from well
previously it was merlin and then his
daughter roma but at the moment it more
or less kind of seemed to be uh
saturnine now in the aftermath or at
least during the events of jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers we saw
the entirety of the captain britain core
was wiped out right they were basically
all destroyed saved for brian braddock
and so jonathan hickman
maintains that there are probably a few
things you need to know in between just
because of the fact that he references
things that happened but the idea
is that saturnine is basically told
morocco has fallen right this land has
basically fallen here and saturnine
seems to know all this stuff now this
all really does kind of make sense just
because of the fact that saturnine is
part of what's called the omniversal
development court and the omniversal
development corps we've talked about
that before
specifically during our video on mad jim
jasper's but the omniversal development
cord is basically this kind of council
this court more or less that exists and
the whole purpose is to monitor
different realities that exist out there
now in the early days when saturnine was
first moved into her position of
becoming the omniversal magistrix her
job was to look through every single
universe and make sure that they were
all following
some kind of former function right which
is to say that mutants arrive around the
same time right like mutant powers
manifest
around the same time within you know
roughly about 100 years or so
something along those lines i'm just
kind of throwing out an arbitrary number
there's nothing to specifically say
100 years but to make sure that like
every earth has some version of like the
avengers different things like that it's
kind of the purpose that it serves
that's why the story of jim jasper's was
so important because during a during
that time you ended up having jim
jasper's who created the fury who wiped
out all the superheroes on earth in his
own universe
earth 238 but saturnine didn't know that
and so that basically led to her
initiating the big push which pissed off
jim jasper's he initiated the jasper's
warp and in order to prevent the
jasper's warp from basically tearing
apart the entire multiverse his whole
reality had to be destroyed right so
that's kind of
the role that she plays is kind of
safeguarding and monitoring the
multiverse and really even the omniverse
if you kind of want to look beyond the
the bigger scope here but that's why she
basically says like i need the tarot
cards because if a rocco has fallen that
means that the the god ammonth or
whatever he is
is basically making his move and there's
really no one there to stand in his way
and and the way this is kind of
explained to the way she kind of plays
this off is that
this has been foretold right this has
all kind of been foretold and everything
is coming to pass and so it seems as
though this is sort of a scenario that's
been prophesized to take place
and is finally coming around right it's
actually finally happening so it's like
the octescent story from marvel comics
but on a much grander scale
if you guys get what i'm talking about
but where you end up having what's
called the oracle point right basically
the access point to morocco
uh this portal that banshee and unis the
untouchable and then pass through will
you end up having a few characters here
suddenly this giant beast emerges from
the hole with summoner riding it and
holding banshee and what he basically
says is
banshee's dying fancy is basically dying
here and so it looks like whatever their
effort was as soon as they went down
there
everything popped off and so banshee's
body is of course taken to the healing
gardens inside krakowa and then
apocalypse asked summoner what in the
world had happened and summoner kind of
basically says like we got in there we
were ambushed on our you know on the way
to morocco uh we didn't even get to
where we were supposed to be like unas
the untouchable is
has been taken prisoner like their war
has begun and so with that being the
case apocalypse takes summoner to the
quiet council right magneto charles
xavier
all these guys and basically tells them
everything that's going on the problem
with this
is that what you end up having is
apocalypse you know you have the kind of
case being made to apocalypse that in
order for them this plan to work right
in order for access to a rocko to have
been achieved for all of this
to have kind of come together apocalypse
had to make that portal
in other world and we saw that during
the story of excalibur right that's why
that that portal was created so that all
of this could be achieved that if they
needed to access saturnine they could
travel through the
the curcumin portal to other world and
then access the uh the omniversal
development court and the starlight
citadel and meet with saturnine if they
needed to
the other part of this is that because
apocalypse did that and he constructed
this portal
directly to araco this was done without
the approval of the quiet council he
acted of his own accord but he saw this
as an absolute necessity and so where
summoner basically tells the story and
saying that unesco untitul was taken
prisoner banshee barely escaped with his
life alongside summoner that they have
to essentially get back you know they
they had to grab apocalypse and marshall
as many forces as they can
to bring this war to an end the quiet
council is largely concerned about this
initially because they're going into a
foreign territory but also because
there's some disagreement here in terms
of how it should be happened right one
of the big concerns that storm has is
for example
unesco untouchable that he is a mutant
he's part of the cocoon population
they can't just leave him behind right
the pod the the whole philosophy
of no one being left behind but at the
same time they can't suddenly just walk
in there because they don't really know
what i was going to go on and to take a
force of that size and to go into a
rocco would leave krakowa unguarded now
a really good point is brought up by
kitty pride when she kind of looks
around and she says okay but if the
concern that we have here is that we
leave ourselves vulnerable right you
know we leave ourselves vulnerable
passing through there then why don't we
simply just go through like the portal
to other world right
why don't we simply go through the
portal to avalon you know we can
basically kind of close that portal off
uh we can keep enough forces here to
keep ourselves safe you know to make
sure the island doesn't fall or anything
like that but for whatever forces decide
you know
if the forces of orcas or whatever it is
that's out there if they want to follow
behind us
then they can't right we pass through
the portal to go to avalon we shut the
portal off and everything's done
the issue that apocalypse has is one
that cannot get us directly there
and two the external gate the gate that
exists that goes to a rocko kokoa does
not have full control over it and so
that's when the quiet council says then
we should destroy the portal right like
we should destroy that portal that goes
to a rocco it sucks that we're going to
end up leaving eunice the untouchable
behind but we should shut it off we
cannot get involved into this massive
conflict we're still assembling
ourselves here we've still got a role to
play in the world at whole we still got
all of our own campaigns right you know
the various pills and medicines they're
getting out there they have all kinds of
threats they have to face off against
the mutants are not in a position to
basically vacate krakowa take some of
the most powerful characters into some
unknown realm in the hopes that they can
even survive
let alone defeat forces whatever those
forces happen to be with whatever power
they happen to possess
there's too many unknowns there's too
many variables and what what you know
scouts they did send in there have been
captured
like that right so what what hope do the
rest of these guys have
not only that when you're traveling into
a dimension like that there's no
guarantee the power you have will even
work right there's no guarantee that
magneto's
control over magnetism will work right
there's no no guarantee that'll be there
it could be all the mutants pass through
there and their powers get shut down
they're just regular humans running
around there just running and hiding and
hoping they don't die
with no real means of return and so when
the when it's put to a vote should we
destroy the oracle gate everybody aside
from apocalypse and summoner and storm
basically vote to destroy the gate and
so ultimately what ends up happening
here is the entire quiet council is
overridden
by krakowa himself right agriculture
makes this point in saying understand
you guys are guests here right i allow
you to be on this island but if you're
going to be on this island then you are
what amounts to house guests
and a man doesn't walk into another
man's home and start telling him what's
what
doesn't work that way and if that's how
you guys want to be then i can kick you
guys off right i can make my island
inhospitable i can have all the plants
start producing carbon dioxide and make
this place unbreathable for you i can do
any number of things
right and so if this is going to be the
case then understand
that curcumin or that that oracle gate
stays open it does not close this
and that's the definitive statement
offered by or really made by kakoa and
there's no real way i mean i guess the
quiet council could ignore him but the
repercussions would be
extreme and so in response to that uh
apocalypse is basically told all right
fine you can
you can do your mission if you need to
but you will have it without the
authority and without the support of
this council meaning you're on your own
that's basically what it is right and so
apocalypse says okay fine
then i will ask for volunteers and so we
actually end up getting
some pretty formidable characters here
for volunteers you get lorna so
basically you get polaris you end up
getting a havoc who of course can
channel
ambient solar energy you have you know
apocalypse and summoner of course but
then you also have beast and you have
archangel now here's an important thing
to understand here when it comes to
beast and archangel they're not the
heaviest of hitters right not by any
stretch of the imagination
but when you combine them with somebody
like siren who of course
is basically banshee you know more or
less has the same powers as banshee you
have the intelligence of hank mccoy
you've got the uh you've got the the
pride and you've got the you know what
abilities you know archangel has he's
only really there because he doesn't
really trust apocalypse right he's like
i don't really trust him he's always up
to something i want to make sure he
doesn't do anything and if he does and
i'm going to go ahead and take him out
but then they're also basically met by
monet saint croix and monese and kroy is
probably the most
prominent probably the the most
interesting of the characters here
because she's kind of this combination
of like standard superhero abilities and
then some of the things that wolverine
has for example she has enhanced hearing
she can see at night she has telepathy
to a degree
she has some really cool powers right
some really cool abilities she's sort of
a hodgepodge
kind of a frankenstein character in
terms of her abilities what she can do
and and so on and so forth and so once
everybody
essentially dives in right once they
arrive on the scene they see this
massive attack being launched
on the starlight citadel right that's
being launched in other world on the
starlight citadel itself and then you
end up having you know unis the
untouchable of course who's being strung
up and all that kind of stuff and
apocalypse witnessing everything that's
going on and seeing that his children
are leading all of this apocalypse
actually cries because he regrets all of
this he regrets that his kids are doing
this right and so at the end of the day
he says like you know these are my
children right they're my horsemen
they're my children it's my job to make
sure they're okay
and so while all that's going on at
least everything going on in other
otherworld
you end up picking up here with uh with
rachel summers and
cable and the idea is that they're
reading the mind of banshee in order to
uncover
everything that had gone on and this is
kind of interesting here because you
would think this would be the most
obvious solution that apocalypse trusts
summoner right because summoner is
basically his grandchild this is his
grandson but you would think that other
people would say okay let's verify the
authenticity of what it is that's being
said here by apocalypse and summoner
let's basically scan the mind of banshee
and find out what these memories are
and as soon as rachel and cable dive
into his mind they begin to realize that
something's off
right this something's not quite right
here when they're basically picking up
with banshee and they're picking up a
summoner and they're picking up with
unes the untouchable entering into this
realm
something seems to be off and so picking
up with the current moment you basically
have apocalypse who approaches his
children and says like i can't believe
that this is real right that you live
it's more than i'd hoped for this has
always been my dream and they kind of
approach him and say you know we don't
want to see you
as the man that you are now we want to
see you as the man that we remember a
man who stood on his two feet a man who
was prideful who was a warrior king you
know a warrior god
we want to see you that way and of
course apocalypse stands and says he has
so many things that he wanted to say
right he has so many questions and he
says tell me of a rocco tell me
if it fell by what miracle have you
returned to me right
like what happened here how did you get
to this place how did you survive all
this time because i thought all of you
guys were gone
and so they basically tell apocalypse
like they don't really imagine this how
they've gone through as being any kind
of a miracle but ultimately like you
ended up having genesis who basically
fell so the the wife of apocalypse their
mother is essentially gone
and that ultimately they became who they
were because there was no way to avoid
it
there was no way to avoid this hellish
landscape that in order to survive you
had to fight but for them it's not
necessarily the worst thing because
remember
apocalypse's entire life is bent on the
idea of
testing right only this strong deserve
to survive that's kind of the
undercurrent with this whole thing and
that's why they say like regret is for
the weak right we were born strong
in that place only the fits survive and
here we are
right only only the strongest are able
to survive and that's why we survive
because we are among the strongest
and from there he's basically asked do
you know what it is that kept us alive
all this time right war reports
approaches them and says do you know
what kept us alive all this time it was
not
love and in turn they kill apocalypse
and it's like holy cow like it's the
most insane thing and then you pick up
with rachel and you pick up with cable
they're still probing through the mind
of banshee and they come to the
realization
that summoner was a plant he set all
this up he was never on the side of
apocalypse he was a means to an end to
get apocalypse here and then to bring
apocalypse down and as they're poking
through and as they're they're kind of
looking around in the whole scenario
they end up coming across
saturnine and saturnine immediately
picks up on the fact that she that
they're trying to read her mind even if
it is saturnine
in the past right and when before all
this is happening in the current moment
and saturnine says
you're looking in the wrong place right
like you're looking for the you're
looking for the wrong thing a great game
is a foot and if you want to play
if you want to win then this is what you
want this is what you need
find it and she shows them this thing
now this is important because this is
saturnine's mind
basically crossing time and space right
it's like if you
read your your your dad's mind right and
and
it's like if right now today at 7 28 p.m
on september 23rd you read your dad's
mind and you ended up reading his mind
or
you saw you experienced his memory from
like a year and a half ago when he was
talking to his boss
and his boss started talking to you like
he realized you were there and started
talking to you that's the kind of power
that we're talking about communicating
through memories is absolutely insane
like it's a crazy display of power but
saturnine is an exceedingly powerful
character right she's wildly capable in
her own right and so where saturn nina
is called by her forces and asks
are you going to do anything about this
here ultimately her response is
no i'm probably not going to and it's
not because saturnine doesn't care
it's because there's a bigger picture
going on here there's a much bigger
event taking place
and so with apocalypse incapacitated
this is a huge deal because the queen on
the chessboard is basically down right
it's basically out and all anybody
can really do is marshal what forces
they have that's the power of apocalypse
if apocalypse were at 100 full strength
he probably could have ended this threat
in no slow fashion right all it would
take is for him to grow himself to like
2000 feet tall
and just start blasting everything with
massive amounts of energy right that's
the kind of power that we're talking
about here and so in response to that
you end up having cable who leaves
rachel summers he goes running to
cyclops and jean grey and says you have
to see this thing right you have to see
this and so because of the fact that
this this object is in the mind of cable
right in the sense that he recalls it
from his memory jean grey reads his mind
passes the thoughts to to cyclops and
basically says we have to go find this
artifact whatever this artifact is right
we don't know what it is but they're
like we have to go find it this energy
source this device whatever it is
saturnine sent us there and if saturning
says it's a thing we need to find that
it means it's a thing we need to find
there's a great big huge set of events
taking place here
and we don't know what it is for those
of you guys who are coming to this from
like our recent videos on avengers and
new avengers this is how hickman does
things right like in hindsight we can
kind of just roll through avengers new
avengers and make sense of everything as
we go along
because we knew it all right after
having read the whole thing like we
basically knew we read a reddit story
that was already completed from
beginning to end
with this we don't know how this is
gonna end and this is the issue that we
run into with jonathan hickman
we end up i know a lot of you guys have
a lot of questions we end up with more
questions than we have answers to it's
just the nature of jonathan hickman but
that's what i love about it is it all
pays off right it all works you end up
having money saying kroy who manifests
your telepathic ability and starts
talking to saturnine and says you have
to do something about this right like
you can't just let this massive battle
take place
with all these people dying and do
nothing you have to get involved somehow
and the response of saturnine
is i will do what i want when i want and
how i want in this place
and you or nobody else here is going to
tell me what it is that i need to do if
i want to get involved i'll get involved
if i do not get involved
trust that there's a reason for it but
ultimately the x-men team doesn't really
seem to hear these words and so it leads
to polaris basically saying if she
doesn't want to get involved we'll make
her get involved and so she ends up
using her control over magnetism to
literally start
pulling apart the starlight citadel in
order to force saturnine's hand in order
to force her to
get involved and so what it does here is
it transitions over to jean grey and to
cyclops and to cable and the problem
that they have is that once they arrive
on this this location they of course
meet advanced idea mechanics scientists
and what this looks like is that it
looks like it's on the orca space
station right they basically
they basically on right back into the
lion's den from where it all kicked off
with house of x
to attain whatever this device happens
to be and so in the midst of all this
saturnine basically says okay like she
recognizes the cyclops and jean
and cable have finally accessed this
device and she says
now i can make my move and she pops back
down and immediately stops everybody but
like everyone stops fighting now
this is the power that saturnine has by
turning to various magics and things at
her disposal she's able to
essentially i don't know i wouldn't
necessarily go as far as to say warp
reality but she's certainly able to
impose her will
on everybody there and it's one of these
things where as we kind of bounce back
and forth you end up having cable who
uses his energy sword which is basically
a lightsaber let's just call it a
lightsaber
to cut a hole through this energy source
through this this fear to access
whatever it is that's inside but then
you have her asking the question to
these various forces to
annihilation and so on like what
foolishness would would bring you here
and lead you to believe that you could
somehow topple me
inside this realm like here i am god why
would you do this of what
like what foolish effort would this be
like why try this in the first place and
the response is
because we serve our lord and liege
right because we were sent here by our
lord and leech presumably amith right
like we serve on his behalf
and if you kill me that's fine like it's
not a huge deal you know like i'll die
but somebody else will take my place and
we will throw as many people as we need
to
in order to get to you because our goal
is not to access the starlight citadel
that's not where we stop our goal
is to access the main marvel universe
and to take over krakowa right to
basically take back what's rightfully
ours and then presumably
expand that sphere of power and
influence back out into the rest of the
world we don't really know what that
intention is i don't believe it's simply
that mundane and that basic that seems
way too simple for somebody like
jonathan hickman right there's something
much much bigger going on here and so
what ends up happening
is the various superheroes who are here
are sent on what's up what amounts to a
kind of
a kind of journey right they're
basically told travel to these locations
and grab these weapons and you will
fight these forces when you get back
right it's basically setting up an
honorable duel that's really what it is
it's setting up this kind of honorable
duel to ensure that if this whole thing
happens that it happens according to a
pre-ordained plan again we don't know
anything about this plan
we don't know anything about this stuff
we simply just know that it exists out
there
but we do know that these various
weapons are weapons that we have heard
of before right the twilight blade the
red vermillion the red sword of war
colony the black bone of amduoid seducer
pog or pog
purity alluvium and the muramasa blade
like we know these weapons some of what
most of them we know some of them we
don't but we know these things
right they simply go by different names
right them you know muramasa the sword
of might the starlight sword
grass cutter the god killer sword
warlock the soul sword just these
different these different names for
these these different weapons that we're
all familiar with you know the light of
galador the skybreaker these are all
exceedingly powerful weapons right these
ten swords have to be accessed they have
to be taken
and when those swords are brought in
then in turn they'll be used for
whatever battle you know this massive
conflict is going to lead to
this kind of final final conflict more
or less this kind of final war this
final you know battle but nonetheless
it's it's
it's jonathan hickman at his best right
it's jonathan hickman basically saying
hey guys some crazy things are gonna
happen
and then like we have a boatload of
questions and it's like but i mean like
what is all this like what are you okay
a lot of things are gonna happen but
like what's going to happen jonathan
hickman like what's like what is what's
the whole idea behind all this and
hickman's like you just gotta wait and
see that's all it is
that's really all this is is this a
teaser for a great big huge event that's
going to
going to play out but it's jonathan
hickman as his at its finest so if you
find yourself frustrated if you find
yourself confused
don't worry you're not alone but stick
with me i promise stick with me
and we will get through this because it
will prove to be something epic
because if i'm a betting man right if
i'm a betting man i will bet
all the money in my pockets to all the
money in your pockets that we're
probably going to end up seeing mad jim
jasper somewhere along the line in this
jonathan hickman x-men run with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and i will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you